hi here we go here we go dozen roses for
no reason at all I felt in my mind how
could I do that if I don't love her and
then she's gonna say oh he must love me
because he did that that's why I didn't
do a lot of romantic things I am a
pretty romantic guy and I know you find
that hard to believe
no a lot of people find that hard to
believe I think the whole world finds
that hard them away I'm such a tough guy
it's hard to believe that I think I'm so
manly it's hard to believe that I could
be in love with you egocentric it's
ridiculous for all these people he's
talking about a lot of people don't
believe I'm romantic buzz going on a lot
of people these guys in the room were
talking about whether you're romantic
about who thinks you're not romantic I
could be and where was up for a
commitment which I am now and I wasn't
at the time so that's you know that's
that I can't even believe there's just
seven months later I mean I made a
couple of phone calls like once maybe
like a week after we broke up or
something right yeah I'm in a way the
other part of this intensions thing is
I'm saying every marriage marta for a
really long time I mean you know how I
feel about that how do you feel about
how do you feel about that she knows
wherever explaining it to you know it's
gone come on every second Ralph I'm not
asking you to marry me setting up a
videotape and certainly not tomorrow in
person but I would like to think that if
we got back together and we became a
couple again and it was working that
somewhere off in the distant future
would be you know the possibility of
marriage
why wait to see private parts I went to
a lot of screenings yes there were
certain parts you knew we're gonna get
applause yeah that's one of them yes
could you go back all right I'll give
you a little bit enough that somewhere
off in the distant future would be you
know the possibility of attention I'm
trying to make light heart of a serious
ending but yeah I don't want to I don't
want to be running around anymore I mean
I'm kind of repeating things I've told
you and different conversations over the
last couple months but I don't want to
be running around anymore I do want to
get married I mean yeah I could see
myself marrying you especially if you
were interested in marrying me but
that's getting ahead of myself but I
want I want you to know that at least I
have something like that in mind that
I'm not just you know dangling that
marriage desperate like this you just go
to anything you know I'm not saying I'm
not a model but I'm telling you I'm
ready to like commit myself would have
been married you guys get back together
did you dump her like a month later
no no she dumped me again no I was
really nice really matter I was totally
like housebroken by then right
she didn't want that she didn't want
that yes you're still in love with the
other guy
I know yeah I miss you I miss you I miss
you
nothing's been the same since you left
and I won't even try to hide that none
of the relationships have worked because
of you become his whole life's a mess
because if one day Mary leaves you to
save this tape and just substitute her
name my life please I asked you and you
lost your lover and I lost your best
friend okay now here's what she gained
you gained a lover and you gain the best
friend again a couple of lovers or
gained one lover but I gain no friends I
have no I there's nobody there to come
home to the call to tell all the great
stuff and and like right now I feel my
professional life is like at a nine and
my personal life is it like a two having
sex in a rap is like right now I'm at a
nine professionally that's like to say
listen man I'm pretty sure I'm going
places yeah but my love life's a tattoo
time for more bababooey math yeah